yeah and a warning that some of the
detail really is quite disturbing
five-year-old logan mowangi uh his body
was found in the river ogmore in
bridgend on the 31st of july
last year he had suffered
what doctors described as catastrophic
injuries 56 of them in total
including injuries to his internal
organs including his brain
and liver he had suffered severe uh
bruising the jury at cardiff crown court
behind me here had taken a little over
five hours they only retired yesterday
afternoon following a nine week or a
near nine week trial
and they only took around five hours and
in the last few minutes they have
delivered guilty verdicts
to ang harrod williamson she is the
mother of logan muangi uh also john cole
who is the stepfather
of logan and as you say a teenage
defendant who we can't name for legal
reasons all three of them found guilty
of murder
and perverting the course of justice the
evidence shown during this trial has
been quite remarkable and it illustrates
the web of lies
which the defendants
carried out in the immediate hours
in the middle of the night after what
happened to that small boy and it
started
with a 999 call from ang harred
williamson who was calling the police uh
to falsely report logan missing
please please help me please where are
you
my son is
i know it's really full-on and it's
really scary
you heard um and harrod refer to the
little boy as logan williams williamson
in that 999 call he was also known by
that name the the plot uh from cole and
williamson was to deny all knowledge of
what had happened they had woken up not
knowing where logan had gone that failed
spectacularly during the trial because
cctv footage at 2 45 in the morning
showed john cole and the teenage
defendant leaving the house carrying
logan's body around two to three hundred
meters down through the park uh to the
river ogmore where his body was dumped
in the time in the eight or nine minutes
or so uh that coal and the teenage
defendant were out of the property
uh williamson
or what he's seen on cctv footage is
curtin's opening lights going on and off
in logan's bedroom that was proof enough
for the jury that ang harrid williamson
logan's mother was also guilty of murder
she had claimed that she was asleep the
whole time but the cctv footage from
houses close by had shown
that there was that movement in the
house that lights were going on and off
the web of lies continued even once
police had arrived at the house in in
bridgend because cctv footage from a
doorbell some houses down
saw
john cole
and the teenage defendant running up and
down by the river shouting logan's name
uh claiming to sort of help police in
the search
they had dumped logan's body just a few
hours before now as the judge delivered
as the verdicts were delivered by the
jury and harred williamson collapsed to
the floor shouting no no no no she was
told to remain quiet
by
the judge here the evidence has been
horrific throughout this trial
and there were warning signs social
services were involved with this family
and the jury heard how the teenage
defendant who had
come across various carers during his
life had mentioned how he wanted to kill
the five-year-old and wanted to kill
logan there had been heated arguments
neighbors have told me
this morning
on the street how there were heated
arguments between
and harried williamson and her partner
john cole
frequently
and the jury also heard about how
logan muwangi's arm had previously been
broken and he had been punished by his
mother and stepfather by being made to
do press-ups to burn off energy being
told to stand in the corner for half an
hour at a time if he was misbehaving he
wasn't given any of the takeaway food if
they were having a takeaway and given
cereal
instead a truly horrific case here and
the jury took very little time after
what was a very long
trial here in cardiff finding
logan's mother
and harry williamson and his stepfather
john cole and a teenage defendant who we
can't name all guilty of murder and
perverting the course of justice